so let's say that this circle looking
thing represents a hole we've already
seen a couple of situations we said hey
look we can divide this into
two equal pieces
and if we shade in one of them so one of
these equal pieces that would be one
half and then if we shade in two of them
this would be two halves so let me color
that in a little bit better so this
right over here
i've divided into two equal pieces and
i'm shading in two of these equal pieces
so what fraction of the whole do i have
shaded in
well we've seen this multiple times this
is two
halves
two halves of the entire figure and we
see we've shaded in the entire figure so
this is equal to
this is equal to one whole
one whole and we could do that we don't
have to just split it into two equal
parts we could split it into
let's see we could split it into three
equal parts so let's say we were to
split into three equal parts let me do
that my best attempt to draw three equal
parts
three equal parts looks like a mercedes
symbol
and that's my best i can draw a little
bit better job of that i'm going to
be clear that i'm trying to make them
equal
so that's three equal parts and then if
we were to actually shade in the three
equal parts
if we were to shade in the three equal
parts so that would be one of the three
so that's one-third
two-thirds
two-thirds and
three
thirds so once again
three-thirds
three-thirds is equal
is equal to
one whole
now what if we were to do something on
some level even simpler
what if we just take our whole and we
divide it into only one equal section
well i've already done that this is one
equal section right over here and then i
were to select that one equal section
so
i were to select it so let me color it
in
so i have one section and i'm going to
shade it in
so what fraction what fraction of the
whole do i now have shaded in
well i had one equal section to begin
with
i had one equal section to begin with
and i shaded in that one equal section
so i have one once
of this shaded in and this is also
clearly an entire hole
so this is also equal
to
a hole and i think you see a pattern
here two seconds three thirds or one one
these all represent the exact same value
they all represent a whole and you would
also see this if you were to draw a
number line
so if you were to draw a number line
so this is zero this is one we could
keep on going
well this is one one if i would say well
between zero and one i just have one i
divide into one equal chunk well that's
just this whole thing right over here
and if i were to move one of those equal
chunks i would get i would get to
i get to one if i divide it into two
equal chunks if i divide it into two
equal chunks and if i
if i jump if i make two jumps one
two jumps i still end up at one if i
divide into three equal sections so
let's say one
one two
three equal sections and i make three
jumps one
two
three i end up at one again so two
seconds three thirds one one or one over
one these all are another are different
ways of representing the number one or
one whole